[Music]
maybe drive putting them in the
recycling he's wearing blue this country
desperately needs new sports we've been
playing the same games for centuries
don't touch the trash can is just one of
the many new competitions that I'm
putting my celebrity brand behind -
expensive for you how about shin kickin
[Music]
way to turn out for shin kicking the
old-time champ of this game is my coffee
table what a painful repetitive
experience which reminds me don't forget
to watch season 16 of The Walking Dead
on AMC talk about the pot calling the
kettle now from the culture that brought
you bird flu this is phlegm battle I'm
getting parts just watching in between
rounds they get a jolly rancher to
replenish their saliva juices but all
these pale in comparison is a brand new
sport we play in our office every Monday
it's called pants it's exactly what it
sounds like and the rules are simple
points are awarded for pants in a fellow
staff member once the pants have been
yanked off completely Sleeping Beauty
rules are then enforced that's where the
staffers frozen until they receive a
soft kiss from their true office love
said kiss must be soft a hard kiss will
result in you having to pick up bagels
for breakfast the next morning side note
if you yell out to actors who sort of
look alike you can unfreeze a limb of
your choice if you're caught over
tightening your belt HR is called in to
loosen it a minimum of two holes but
I've seen them take an entire belt
before the game is complete once you win
by two couldn't be simpler two two three
four
not his true office love we're headed to
overtime sending the coconut oil if he
doesn't find true love's kiss by the
playoffs next week he can no longer wear
pants that work for one calendar year
the game can be played outside of the
office if a co-worker is spotted around
town by yelling snow day